[Música]
con múltiples propósitos en su agenda el
presidente de estados unidos joe biden
avanza con su gira por medio oriente que
incluye paradas en israel y en arabia
saudita que busca el presidente de byd
en fortalecer aún más los lazos con su
gran aliado en la zona israel pero
también mostrar que eeuu no ha dejado de
lado el respaldo que le da a palestina y
también que respalda la formación de dos
estados como solución para el conflicto
en esa zona del mundo en arabia saudita
maiden también habló de la producción de
petróleo el espinoso tema de los
derechos humanos y posibles
acercamientos entre el reino de arabia
saudita e israel para conformar un
bloque para así hacer contrapeso a la
república islámica de irán en esa región
un poco del contexto de la visita del
mandatario se lo explicamos en el
siguiente reportaje veamos
by then apuesta por una solución al
conflicto palestino-israelí aunque
todavía sin propuestas claras el
presidente estadounidense recalcó que el
terreno no está preparado la idea de dos
estados sigue como la propuesta de
washington a este conflicto de décadas
pero este
el pueblo palestino se merece un estado
que sea independiente soberano viable y
contiguo dos estados para dos pueblos
ambos tienen raíces profundas en esta
tierra viviendo lado a lado
e incluso si el terreno no está
preparado en este momento para
reestablecer las negociaciones eeuu y mi
administración no se rendirán para
tratar de traer a los palestinos ya los
israelíes a ambos bandos más cerca y
unidos de una propuesta bien recibida
por palestina pero que aseguran podría
expirar pronto la energía la oportunidad
de una solución de dos estados en la
frontera de 1967 puede estar disponible
hoy y puede no permanecer por mucho
tiempo
este viernes badén se consagró como el
primer presidente estadounidense en
realizar un trayecto aéreo de israel a
arabia saudita horas antes del despegue
riada anunció que permitirá que todas
las aerolíneas sobrevuelen su espacio
aéreo en un acercamiento de arabia
saudita con el estado hebreo dos países
sin relaciones diplomáticas una postura
que comparten los países de la liga
árabe hasta que no se resuelva el
conflicto con palestina tú desde la
historia de after intense behind the
scenes diplomacy guys saudí y hoy es un
día histórico tras una intensa
diplomacia entre bastidores entre arabia
saudita de eeuu el espacio aéreo saudita
ahora estará abierto a las compañías
aéreas israelíes
en el viaje de biden hay edad se espera
que eeuu pueda restablecer la relación
con un país al que un día prometió
convertir en un paria para la comunidad
internacional luego del asesinato del
periodista jamal hawking en 2018
pero biden que conoce muy bien la región
del medio oriente se encuentra con una
región del golfo muy diferente los
estados de la península arábiga y del
golfo pérsico son ahora países que saben
de política exterior saben negociar y
también defender sus intereses y saben
el poder que tienen por ser productores
de petróleo
eeuu busca entonces volver a tener una
posición de liderazgo en esa región pero
ahora hay también poderes regionales que
lideran pero como entonces va a sortear
el presidente de byd en las críticas de
sentarse a negociar a conversar acerca
de temas tan complicados y criticados
como los derechos humanos en un país
como por ejemplo arabia saudita que
pedirán estos países a cambio o que van
a pedir por ejemplo a cambio los
palestinos para negociar otra vez con
los israelíes o que van a pedir entonces
al negociar un incremento en la
producción de crudo que tratará de
ayudar un poco a la economía mundial que
está viendo unos altos precios en el
momento podrá entonces el presidente de
byd en cumplir con todas sus intenciones
en medio oriente lo vamos en unos
minutos aquí en el debate de france 24
para eso hemos invitado al señor
mauricio jaramillo fácil él es profesor
de relaciones internacionales de la
universidad del rosario se encuentra en
la ciudad de bogotá en colombia en
washington está emilio viano él es
analista internacional y docentes del
departamento de justicia ley y sociedad
de la universidad george washington le
desean recuerdo que ustedes también
hacen parte de esta conversación pueden
dejar todas sus preguntas y comentarios
a través de nuestras redes sociales
estamos en twitter en instagram y en
facebook en donde no se encuentran como
france24 bajo ese arroba sant y luego
que es mi cuenta personal la etiqueta es
un numeral el debate efe 24 también en
youtube pueden seguir nuestra señal en
streaming aprovecho para saludar a las
personas que también nos están
escuchando a través de nuestro podcast
los invito para que escuchen todos los
contenidos de nuestro programa que ya
está disponible en app el podcast en
spotify dice y tuning
bueno pues comienzo entonces con
nuestros invitados para hacerles la
pregunta de punto de partida para este
debate el punto de partida para mauricio
en la ciudad de bogotá bienvenido al
programa gracias por acompañarnos y que
busca entonces el presidente by de en el
medio oriente cuáles son sus verdaderas
intenciones yo daba un perfil general
pero desde su análisis y desde su punto
de vista cuál es mauricio bienvenido
muchas gracias santiago por la
invitación y un saludo también para
emilio yo creo que básicamente tiene
tres objetivos el primero es recuperar
el liderazgo de eeuu como
facilitadora en el 27 cual es tino
israelí hace mucho tiempo de eeuu dejó
de ser influyente desde la época de bill
clinton
igualmente control que fueron cuatro
años prácticamente votados a la basura
en segundo lugar creo que tiene el deber
de volver a ser influyente con aliados
como israel y arabia saudí con quienes
el gobierno de vahidi no había tenido
una relación bastante fría por decirlo
de algún modo había sido muy crítico de
la situación de los derechos humanos en
arabia saudí y se especulaba que tenía
una no tan buena relación con las nuevas
autoridades de de la vida entonces me
parece que ahí hay una recuperación de
los aliados y en tercer lugar creo que
hay
eeuu tiene el interés de hacerle
contrapeso a esta guerra energética que
se ha lanzado con rusia a propósito del
tema de ucrania y obviamente pues la
producción de crudo saudí e incluso la
producción de gas en israel son dos son
dos temas que lo llevan a esta gira
y le pregunto lo mismo emilio viano
también aprovecho para saludarlo en la
ciudad de washington el señor piano
gracias por estar con nosotros y que
busca el presidente baile en el medio
oriente cuál es su agenda más allá de
estos temas que he mencionado en la
introducción del programa que son
prácticamente los los temas
superficiales digámoslo así
bueno yo creo que en bailén tomo en
cuenta también la situación al interior
de los estados unidos.el tiene ahora el
nivel de aprobación más bajo en su
presidencia y particularmente en un año
de elecciones esto presenta un desafío
muy grave para él para su liderazgo como
presidente como líder de los demócratas
así que es un viaje también para crear
una visión más positiva de él sin duda
en su gira policial por ejemplo
y ha generado reacciones muy positivas
por ciertos grupos muy influyentes en
los estados unidos a parte de los judíos
que viven aquí en el país que no
necesariamente siempre apoyan a israel
hay millones de evangélicos que apoyan a
israel ciegamente pues que dice en la
biblia les dio a los israelíes a los
hebreos este término en nadie tiene el
derecho de vivir y de cosechar allí así
que claramente el hecho que él durante
esta visita
y repitió el reafirmó el sacrosanto
compromiso de washington por la
seguridad del estado judío así como su
resolución a utilizar todos los
elementos a su disposición para
garantizar que era no sea la
convocatoria ha generado una reacción
muy positiva en grupo es que
generalmente votan republicanos
particularmente el sur de los eeuu
además hay todo el problema de los
precios de la gasolina de la nación y
por eso la visita a árabes abrirá para
generar más producción de crudo para que
se pueda rellenar y mantener un precio
más bajo así que no es solamente el
aspecto internacional la visita a los
países donde está pero el mercado
internacional
la estimación dentro del país es en
cuanto al mercado internacional o la
situación interna pero qué hay de la
situación en medio oriente señor ya no
hago la ronda
es una región de medio oriente en un
contexto muy particular en este momento
la que se encuentra el presidente de byd
en en esta oportunidad se encuentra un
conflicto abierto en yemen un conflicto
en siria que está pues sin finalizar
israel tratando de establecer relaciones
con los países árabes ya lo ha logrado
con los emiratos árabes y con bahrein y
se encuentra también unos liderazgos muy
distintos unos
líderes de las diferentes monarquías
allí en los países del golfo que son
líderes en algunos casos muy jóvenes con
una visión de la región muy distinta a
la que puede tener el presidente de
bailén que conoce bien esa región como
yo lo como yo lo decía en la
introducción como es este medio oriente
que se encuentra el presidente va a
tener en esta gira pero realmente
tenemos que tomar en cuenta el como se
dice en inglés el elefante en el cuarto
que es irán del cual no se ha hablado
mucho
el líder es estadounidense hayden ha
asegurado este jueves que sigue creyendo
que la diplomacia es la mejor manera de
contener ayer han anticipado que
continuará trabajando
la comisión para contrarrestar a otras
anima amenazas de irán en la región
también ha advertido que no esperará
para siempre claro que la api del líder
israelí ha sostenido por su parte que
las palabras no detendrán el régimen de
los ayatolás y que la única manera que
existan del programa de armas nucleares
sería poner sobre una mesa una amenaza
militar creíble así que hay allí una
digamos alguna falta de la misma opinión
de acuerdo entre los israelíes y bailén
hayden y afirmó que sólo recurriría a un
extremo para decir la intervención
militar contra irán como último último
recurso israel
el acuerdo nuclear y ha defendido
siempre adoptar una línea más dura
contra de teherán las negociaciones para
regresar a la senda del pacto están de
nuevo en un punto muerto pero tenemos
que tomar en cuenta lo que pasará la
semana próxima cuando putin llegará de
la cndh el logan de turquía también y
otros para más de un contrapeso claros y
de orden en la región ese tema que
también vamos a analizar aquí en el
debate señor viano mauricio en la ciudad
de bogotá su perspectiva de cuál es este
medio oriente que se encuentra el
presidente baten en esta visita hemos
dado algunas pinceladas ya vamos a
hablar del tema de irán y este bloque
que quieren formar con israel para
defender ese hacer contrapeso a la
influencia iraní en la zona
bueno pues básicamente creo que es un
medio oriente con muchos conflictos de
un lado tenemos la guerra civil en yemen
que no se ha podido terminar en la que
eeuu básicamente desde que estaba idem
se ha retirado luego tenemos una especie
de renacimiento de israel en la
normalización de relaciones con bahrein
con marruecos con emiratos árabes y
ahora una posible normalización con
arabia saudita por lo menos lazos más
más estrechos
yo tengo la impresión de que irán está
saliendo del aislamiento en buena medida
porque él está proporcionando tecnología
militar a rusia para la guerra en
ucrania tengo un poco la impresión que
se empiezan a formar bloques en una
turquía que está sacando provecho de una
suerte de neutralidad mucho más activa
tradicionalmente había sido aliada o
mucho más cercana israel hoy ha buscado
un equilibrio y si hay un acercamiento
con el mundo árabe que nos parece
interesante
y no se nos puede olvidar que en esta
dinámica del medio oriente el gobierno
de ella y rapid start y benet viene
tremendamente debilitado es un gobierno
que no ha podido garantizar niveles
mínimos de gobernabilidad luego de una
de un periodo extensísimo de benjamín
netanyahu
entonces israel es uno de los estados en
el último tiempo más debilitados y está
saliendo si se quiere una herramienta
que fue sometido durante los últimos
años pero me parece que asistimos a una
política de nuevo de bloques en la que
hay una si se quiere disputa geopolítica
entre turquía eeuu francia reino unido
por ver quién es el que tiene mayor
influencia iba a tener finalmente mayor
influencia quien uno pueda tener
incidencia en el desmonte de la
violencia entre israel y palestina quien
pueda tener una incidencia en la
reconfiguración del post conflicto
iraquí y el xxi y eventualmente que
pueda pacificar a yemen que es no los
grandes conflictos de la zona mauricio
que están
importante o qué tan peligrosa es esa
influencia de irán en la zona para que
países como israel y arabia saudita se
sienten a establecer relaciones que por
años han estado completamente
congelada ni siquiera congelada no han
existido ningún tipo de relaciones entre
israelí y varios países del mundo árabe
para que los lleve a unirse contra esta
república islámica
irán no es una amenaza y básicamente lo
que es una disputa geopolítica por
razones distintas
israel básicamente porque irán este uno
de sus enemigos declarado y arabia
saudita porque pretende debilitar el
poder chiíta que en el último tiempo ha
sido muy importante en escenarios como
el iraquí que yo mencionaba el libanés y
obviamente en siria ahí lo que vemos es
una suerte de guerra fría en la que
existe una serie de poderes sobre todo
sunitas en la cabeza arabia saudí que
quieren contrarrestar este poder que ha
venido acumulando en el último tiempo
irán perduran es un estado que tiene muy
poca capacidad de influencia en la
influencia de irán es si se quiere
selectiva hacia acá son del líbano y en
siria hasta cierto punto en esta gira
que reconstruido pero de ninguna manera
es una amenaza para la región la
ciudanía soy dejado en claro muchas
veces que les interesa el programa
nuclear para fines exclusivamente
civiles
señor piano en la ciudad de washington
la meta final de este bloque de esta
alianza de esta colaboración entre estos
países con la ayuda de eeuu y de israel
es trazar un sistema regional de defensa
en diferentes áreas de la península
arábiga y también de medio oriente con
diferente tipo de armamento que haga
contrapeso a la tecnología militar que
tiende a irán a por ejemplo los drones
iraníes y también porque no mencionar
los los drones que ha desarrollado
turquía que los hemos visto en acción en
la guerra de ucrania
quienes podrían participar allí cómo
están las cargas militares en esta zona
para conformar esta gran alianza este
sistema regional bueno en claramente los
eeuu a estar comprometido y bailén ha
reiterado en la declaración firmada con
la pgje su compromiso con para preservar
la ventaja militar de israel en la
región siguen los eeuu no es digamos un
intermediario
balanceado o neutral ya tiene su
precedente y como parte de esta promesa
ha certificado que mantendrá a los casi
cuatro mil millones de dólares por año
la asistencia militar de washington a
los israelíes cada año hasta el 2028 así
que hablamos de una cifra muy importante
de dinero que además habló de su
entusiasmo para avanzar un paralelo a su
asociación de defensa a través de la
cooperación en tecnología punta como
sistemas láser antiaéreos así que
claramente la prioridad de los eeuu es
de apoyar a israel 30 mientras que
ciertos otros estados también por
razones religiosas a los iraníes
concedidas la mayoría de los árabes en
la misión de los celebrantes etcétera
no comparten esta versión de islam son
sunitas son semillas así que hay allí
una razón para un conflicto y quien va a
predominar será la cuestión del futuro
serán claramente los eeuu no quieren
ponerse al lado de ninguno de los otros
países pero se tendrán que tal vez que
hacerlo con arabia saudita para
verdaderamente intentar de solucionar el
problema de el petróleo de la gasolina
esto podría influir mucho celebraremos a
la reacción de rusia de erdogán de
turquía y de otros países que parecen
alinearse con miran feliz formar un
bloque por parte del otro lado en contra
de balancear digamos esta preferencia de
los estadounidenses para instalar ahora
para los saudíes y otros estados de la
región ya vamos a hablar del tema del
petróleo que es tal vez lo que está aquí
en juego también para eeuu el intento de
el aumento de producción de petróleo por
parte de arabia saudita mauricio usted
decía que irán tal vez no era un país
que ejerciera mucha influencia en la
zona pero si hay algo que preocupa en
esa región es el programa nuclear un
programa nuclear que pues se ha visto
con unos altibajos dependiendo de las
sanciones que tiene a nivel
internacional y que eeuu en algún
momento bajó un poco la guardia durante
la administración obama y trató de
acercarse a teherán hoy en día para
israel sigue siendo una gran amenaza
sigue siendo una gran preocupación y es
una factura que tal vez a arabia saudita
le puede cobrar a eeuu en estas
negociaciones algo que han dicho los
sauditas es que cuando eeuu en 2015
firmó ese acuerdo nuclear con irán se le
olvidó que tal vez tenía que proteger a
su gran aliado que era arabia saudita
que está al lado iraní podía ver
repercusiones desde teherán como ve
usted ahí esa posible negociación y está
este factor del acuerdo nuclear y el
programa nuclear puede entrar en esas
negociaciones puede ser este un punto
importante para conversar entre entre
los mandatarios y entre el mandatario by
denny pues la monarquía saudita
yo creo que es un punto muy difícil yo
creo que tanto arabia saudí como israel
tienen una suerte de inamovible cuando
se trata de irán e israel que era la
posición básicamente de kajran hay que
atacarlo y que es la única manera de
disuadirlo de acceder a la energía
nuclear y en el caso de arabia saudi
pues básicamente está en guerra en una
guerra en directo en el escenario yemení
en una guerra indirecta en el escenario
sirio y obviamente una guerra indirecta
en el escenario iraquí entonces
obviamente ellos no están dispuestos a
entablar ninguna negociación con eeuu
que ponga sobre la mesa la posibilidad
de negociar el programa nuclear iraní
porque es un enemigo declarado histórico
y es mucho más fácil pienso yo para
israel firmar la paz con sus vecinos
inmediatos incluso con los palestinos
que con el propio irán entonces lo veo
muy poco probable yo pensaría de otro
lado santiago que haya un consenso en el
escenario internacional por lo menos los
cinco grandes del consejo de seguridad
reino unido francia estados unidos china
de rusia más alemania- sobre la
necesidad de revivir el pacto nuclear y
eso me parece que va a terminar
ocurriendo y ahí lo que va a haber es un
monitoreo una verificación constante que
irán no nos sobrepase en el
enriquecimiento de uranio
para mantenerse un poco dentro de la
esfera civil pero pero muy difícilmente
israel era necesitaban acceder a entrar
en esa negociación claro sobre todo con
el contexto en el que están en este
momento a nivel internacional señor ya
no en la coyuntura en la que estamos con
este panorama que estamos viendo de la
región lo que pueden ser estas
negociaciones cómo puede reaccionar irán
que tiene una gente revolucionaria una
agenda en la que financia diferentes
grupos en yemen y en el líbano y que
pues representa un reto para ellos a
nivel tecnológico si llega a haber una
alianza militar aquí en la región como
podría reaccionar ellos que podría ser
teherán
bueno no olvidemos que fue el presidente
de trump que renunció el tratado
negociado por el presidente obama con
teherán para limitar sus ambiciones de
tener bombas atómicas así que en cierto
sentido los iraníes tienen razón
dudar un poco las intenciones de los
norteamericanos y de los otros países de
la región que se
consideran aliados de washington
claramente fue un error por parte de
trump y causó un desequilibrio en la
región es claro que dice que quiere ser
el poder militar dominante y hay una
contienda irán quiere también ser un
poder militar y depende de quién va a
apoyar a quién y cómo va a terminar todo
esto esperemos que vayan tenga razón la
diplomacia es la mejor manera de hacerlo
pero al final parece que no está
funcionando como no está funcionando con
los palestinos hubo la visita de
obligación de bailén a mamud abas a los
palestinos hoy pero al final no hay nada
de concreto no no se está hablando aún
de la solución de los estados que
recuentos de aguas nunca a dos estados
los israelíes ya no van a permitir
quieren anexar todo controlar todo así
que la situación muy difícil de
solucionar en un hombre soy muy
optimista sea el futuro hay hay algo
positivo en el sentido que hay una
creciente integración de israel en
oriente próximo con la normalización de
relaciones con marruecos y realizar
sonidos y barrer el baile se ha
comprometido a ayudar a expander esto el
lápiz ya mismo
preguntado pedido que cuando viajará
próximamente
nuevamente al oriente medio que
transmita a los líderes de ahí el qatar
kuwait oman air bag su voluntad de
estrechar lazos y de mantener de entrar
en un acuerdo con estos estados claro el
futuro de palestina ha quedado relegado
al final de la declaración conjunta
si antes de pasar al tema del petróleo
que lo dejo para el último bloque quería
hablar precisamente del tema de
palestina señor viano continuo con usted
rápidamente para hablar este tema y es
esta relación ha estado con muchos
altibajos y en este momento
particularmente washington tenía una
relación muy tensa con palestina a raíz
de la periodista de la muerte de la
periodista de al yazira
que pues muchos medios constataron que
había sido había muerto durante un
cubrimiento debido a un cruce de
disparos y que la bala que la mató fue
proveniente del ejército israelí israel
no no se pronunció al respecto y eeuu
pues tomó una posición un poco
manteniéndose fuera del escenario y eso
no le gustó a palestina y eso tenso la
relación se puede mejorar esta relación
se puede palestina confiar del gobierno
de bailén para mejorar la situación
actual y tal vez que eeuu interceda un
poco anti israel o usted no es optimista
frente a ese tema
bueno con la declaración conjunta de
entre israel y eeuu a los 12 instan solo
a seguir discutiendo los retos y las
oportunidades
de las relaciones entre israelíes y
palestinos y trabajar para fortalecer
posiblemente la calidad de vida de la
población
bailén reafirmó en su apoyo
a una solución de dos estados aunque al
narco les anticipó que no era factible
que sea posible a corto plazo así que no
hay nada nuevo nada muy cool en este
sentido en mi opinión en mauricio su
opinión en torno a este tema usted se
muestra un poco más positivo que el
señor viano o cuál es su opinión sobre
el conflicto palestino-israelí está
prácticamente en un punto muerto no hay
negociaciones no hay conversaciones no
hay avances pero eso sí el que se avanza
es israel cada vez anexando cada vez más
territorios y ocupando más territorio
del lado palestino
sí yo creo que estamos mejor que control
acordémonos que de donald trump propuso
un plan de paz en el que se hablaba de
un estado palestino sin soberanía en el
que se reconoce a jerusalén como capital
de israel y esto es muy grave ahora es
grave lo que estamos viviendo el
asesinato designado a clay
comprobadamente además por parte de la
fuerza de la defensa israelí puso en
evidencia
que lo grave de hoy no es solamente en
la elección de territorios sino que pues
está en en marcha aún un régimen que
recurre a la limpieza étnica al
apartheid y al despojo constante en
medio de eso pensar en la paz es muy
difícil pero lo que uno piensa es que si
algún otras políticas de eeuu para
sentar a israelí apareciera en la mesa
yo pienso que se puede lograr
acordémonos que ya lo intentó
bill clinton en los acuerdos de oslo en
la década de los 90
lo cual puso freno a una de las
violencias producto de la primera
intifada entonces aunque parezca difícil
y yo sé que es muy difícil yo no
descartaría que pone apoyo sobre todo de
francia quien tiene también una agenda
importante en oriente medio con macrón y
ahora con este impulso de bling en y joe
biden pues se relanza de alguna manera
un proceso que no va a dar frutos
inmediatos pero revivir de alguna manera
lo que se tuvo en los acuerdos de oslo
mauricio rápidamente porque la comunidad
internacional no ejerce un poco de
presión sobre israel en esta segregación
que hace del pueblo palestino en esta
limpieza étnica que usted mencionaba y
también porque no hay una presión
internacional sobre arabia saudita en
términos de derechos humanos que es una
de las grandes críticas que le están
haciendo al presidente de bailén en este
momento que está en estos dos escenarios
muy claros y el presidente está
negociando pero no está exigiendo nada
en esa materia
pues básicamente occidente siempre ha
tenido es esta doble moral este doble
estándar con israel con algunas
excepciones hemos visto por ejemplo en
naciones unidas algunos relatores que
han sido muy críticos del sistema de
limpieza étnica en israel muy críticos
de la manera en que se excluye a la
población árabe que hace parte de israel
desafortunadamente las grandes potencias
de occidente en especial eeuu
admirado para otro lado cuando se trata
de la violación de los derechos humanos
esto lo vimos por ejemplo en la reacción
de frente de la muerte designaba clay no
hubo ningún estado de occidente que
condenar a israel
en un contraste marcado cuando se da por
ejemplo violaciones a los derechos de
los periodistas en rusia en bielorrusia
en filipinas donde ha habido o en cuba
donde ha habido movilizaciones
importantes yo aquí occidente
desafortunadamente como decimos en
colombia se tapa con la misma cobija son
aliados se protegen con los mismos
dobles raseros claro y lo triste es que
esto se hace expensas de los derechos
humanos mauricio señor ya no dejamos
para la última parte del programa el
tema del petróleo fundamental en este
momento en el que estamos de la
coyuntura internacional con una alta
inflación con
problemas para abastecer algunos países
ya lo vemos por ejemplo en chili blanca
donde hay un grave problema económico y
político y entre ellos está el
desabastecimiento de petróleo de
combustible y todo esto debido a la
guerra en rusia que ha causado
muchísimos problemas a nivel
internacional
la perspectiva aquí es como la ve usted
señor viano en cuanto a la negociación
que pueda tener baiden como lo decía yo
en la introducción los países del golfo
ya son países que conocen el poder que
tienen al ser productores de petróleo
tienen margen de negociación ya saben
cómo negociar a nivel internacional que
le pueden pedir a cambio el presidente
debaten
por parte de arabia saudita a cambio de
aumentar la producción sabiendo que en
este momento arabia saudita
prácticamente está en el tope de su
capacidad de producción de barriles de
crudo diarios
pero claramente son concesiones
políticas
y claramente por ejemplo quieren que
cese la crítica al príncipe heredero por
la muerte de la noche en el consulado de
arabia saudí en turquía así que hay un
precio que pagar el precio que pagar es
necesario criticar a arabia saudí por la
falta de derechos humanos el estatus de
las mujeres
la matanza del caso de la que matanza en
la cárcel para los disidentes que buscan
más libertad de más derechos humanos
cesa la persecución de las heridas que
ocupan para más de toda la región donde
hay el petróleo en arabia saudí y que
frecuentemente son maltratados por los
suníes para decir aceptar que ellos
pueden hacer lo que quieren pero no
vamos a interferir que no vamos a
recordarles que hay tratados
internacionales derechos humanos de la
mujer es eso yo creo el precio a pagar
como mínimo
para restaurar relaciones que puedan tal
vez entrar irá a aumentar la producción
así que se pueda balancear la digamos lo
que está pasando en el mundo en este
sector energético y pedirle a arabia
saudita que produzca más petróleo cuando
ya está llegando a casi un total de 11
millones de barriles de petróleo por día
es prácticamente su máxima capacidad
quién sabe cuánto más estará pidiendo el
presidente bailén para hacer un poco más
estable los precios sobre todo en eeuu
mauricio lo que tiene en juego eeuu que
tanto está arriesgando en esta
negociación este país norteamericano
eeuu está arriesgando su credibilidad en
materia de derechos humanos sobre todo
porque acordémonos de cuando llegó ayer
a la casa blanca tuvo una postura muy
crítica frente a arabia saudí habló de
la necesidad de aclarar el tema de jacob
y que ya mencionaba evita emilio en
habló de la salida de eeuu de yemen que
era una manera de castigar al régimen de
arabia saudí y se habló de un eeuu como
suele ocurrir con las administraciones
demócratas mucho más coherente y
defensor del tema de los derechos
humanos en oriente medio al al acudir a
una negociación si se quiere cínica a la
que obviamente está obligada por la
coyuntura en rusia yo bailé en pone en
entredicho su credibilidad de eeuu como
un defensor de la democracia de los
derechos humanos como un actor que busca
equilibrios en oriente medio y deja en
evidencia en bastante algo en la manera
en que eeuu está viendo afectado por la
guerra económica que hemos visto a raíz
de la guerra en ucrania lo que hemos
básicamente comprobado es que las
sanciones contra rusia no han tenido el
efecto que se esperaba y que básicamente
hay un problema grave desabasto vientos
sobre todo de gas y menor medida de
petróleo en europa que eeuu se siente
comprometido a abastecer entonces eeuu
trata de seguir abasteciendo a europa
con un hidrocarburos pero me parece que
está sacrificando en buena medida su
imagen como un país defensor de la
democracia los derechos humanos
y eso es un punto que a washington no
quiere ceder ellos esperan que la unión
europea siga comprando les gas sobre
todo de cara al invierno boreal que
comenzará en unos meses y por eso desde
hace ya muchos años atrás venía
presentando obstáculos para la puesta en
marcha del norte stream-2 en su momento
y bueno el escenario no puede ser más
favorable para la venta de petróleo y
gas estadounidense hacia europa
ahora que pues hay completa
incertidumbre en cuanto a lo que pueda
pasar con el suministro de rusia
principalmente a alemania llegamos al
final del programa quiero hacer entonces
las conclusiones hay pocos minutos para
ellas el señor viano su conclusión que
va a pasar de aquí en adelante que vamos
a ver en el escenario el medio oriente
en unos meses desde su perspectiva
de mi punto de vista no haga nada
cambios dramáticos no hará nada
verdaderamente mucho importante
yo pienso que será más como hemos
normalizado una situación difícil
siempre con la posibilidad de conflictos
de guerras y aceptar que es una región
muy difícil a donde hay intereses
enormes a no lograr la paz porque con la
guerra se gana más por ejemplo el sitio
de los eeuu ha de ser el 4 mil millones
de dólares al año ha sido en el verano
porque así que yo creo que no hará
cambios dramáticos al contrario podría
suscitar un desequilibrio
particularmente con lo que está pasando
con rusia y también el rol ambiguo de
turquía que quiere un poco jugar ambos
lados de esta cuestión para mantenerse
digamos como señor va a influir mucho el
resultado final y dejó para el cierre la
conclusión de cierre a mauricio en la
ciudad de bogotá delante
yo pensaría que eeuu va a tratar de ser
mucho más incidente y por lo menos antes
de que se termine el gobierno hay de
intentar una negociación aunque tímida
entre israelíes y palestinos en segundo
lugar creo que arabia saudi vuelve al
escenario de la política regional y
finalmente creo que eeuu va a apostar
por revivir en el pacto nuclear con ira
que es clave en este momento para cerrar
un pasivo que dejó en el strong y en
buena medida también para aumentar la
producción petrolera en el mundo lo cual
es urgente por la situación que se vive
en ucrania pues a mauricio ya emilio
viano a mauricio jaramillo en la ciudad
de bogotá emilio viano en la ciudad de
washington muchas gracias por habernos
acompañado hoy en el programa haber
hecho este análisis para la audiencia de
france 24 en américa latina' ustedes
pueden seguir con nuestra programación
sigan con nosotros
[Música]